oh hi screen junkies it's me Spencer for
honest trailer commentaries
I'm here with Joe my best friend and Dan
my future wife Spencer is my best friend
and Dan is my future wife I love her my
best friend
hey guys if you didn't know by now we're
talking about the room which we just did
an honest trailer of this show we're
gonna be watching the room giving you
our behind-the-scenes look at what we
really thought if it wasn't clear from
the trailer and we wouldn't normally be
giving you some deleted scenes but I
think they all made everything how can
you not how could you not all gold and
also like what is there to say about the
room guys which is why we have an honest
trailer up until now the disaster artist
is the reason we're doing this we've
been talking about doing the room for
many many years but the question always
came back around like what do you say
well let the room speak for itself is
honest trailers to present it honestly
and that movie is very upfront about
what it is very honest I don't know it's
such an enigma
the paradox because the movie is so bold
and it's presentation but I still don't
know what the intent was behind me like
the intent was Tommy Rizzo he's black
comedy yeah yeah is it he's pretending
he's in on says the black comes to be a
black cop yeah which makes it sad the
reason why nothing he does works now is
because now he tries to pretend like
he's been trying to do funny things all
along and now it's just sad like I don't
know like I've been watching his post
room who had his show roommates on for a
little while I don't know if it still
exists there anymore so we watched like
one and it was just like mmm this is
uncomfortable and sad I think it's gone
from set from I think we're actually
back around to inspiring oh god I think
we've come back around he's got a James
Franco movie coming out everybody
this is movie now they know who he is
that's true I think that if the disaster
artist is nominated for an Oscar and
Tommy was oh is at the ceremony this
year will truly be living in the
upside-down Academy please yeah if the
disaster artist is nominated for an
Academy Award I beg you to let Tommy
Wiseau present an Oscar yes it can be it
can be costume design sound editing
sound editing sound mixing you he put so
much work into trying to find out the
difference between shooting on film and
hi-def he has to give Santa toxic right
that's the only director that's ever
shot okay simultaneously on film and HD
who's better qualified to give the
cinematic fact they didn't make it into
it's in the disasters but didn't make it
into the honest trailer is that he just
instead of usually a production rents
camera equipment and they rent digital
or they rent a film and then they shoot
their movie and then they return it to
the equipment place Tom who's out bought
two complete sets to two years two of
like cinema quality film and digital
cameras set them up next to each other
and shot the whole movie on both if
you've never seen the behind the scenes
of there's a there's a sequence of just
the crew trying to build the rig so that
this can happen and they're all just
like why are we doing this and I just
like this guy's like what is the
difference between film and HD and it's
like I'm going to write a book and study
it and it's like why why do you need to
write it what like everyone knows what I
want to see I'm assuming the version of
the room that we know is the film
version okay I want to see the other
version that's the same but six of us
like switches from of course he does
because what of course why wouldn't you
yeah yeah but never a second I thought
you
say the room we know is the one that was
released in theaters I would like to say
the Zack Snyder cut you watched all the
behind the scenes were there any other
nuggets you could glean from that he's a
I mean he's a weirdo of it like we know
this but like he's truly the just a
crazy person like the his auditions were
all super weird he would go and have
them like outside there's so much b-roll
of him complaining about how much how
many people they've had to fire and like
introducing new people to the crew and
hoping that they last a day it's it's
truly bonkers okay sweet yeah all right
well shall we dive into the room let's
do let's do it what a story Joe also he
I think he voted for Trump
[Laughter]
[Music]
in a world where most movies are just
okay one film will be so bizarre so
obsessed and so aggressively bad the
sheer amount of suck will collapse in on
itself like a dying star and explode in
a supernova of unintentional genius tell
me why so stars in rights produces and
directs a film two different vanity
cards before TSW productions Tommy and
Greg Sestero is credited as the like
co-producer of the movie because he was
yeah the plays mark yeah write the book
the disaster artist which you haven't
read it the movies great the book is
better it is just it's insanity I mean
there's things like the fact that they
did that whole rooftop thing in a
complete you know like almost 360-degree
green screen which was very noticeable
and also very time-consuming and then he
visited one of Tommy's warehouses in San
Francisco which has had a horror amic
view of San Francisco which is what he
green-screen into the movie it's
mind-blowing it's mind-blowing I keep
waiting for the Kaufman to reveal that
he had it's just been 15 years of Wow
yeah all right let's keep going financed
by a rumored six million dollars of his
own mysterious fortune and featuring
three long minutes of his own mysterious
questions a man with a singular vision a
unique personal style with the world
maybe it's okay to gank under dreams
how can they say this about me I don't
believe it I show them journey to b-roll
of San Francisco so much fear Oh Johnny
your everyday all-american Dracula you
know people don't office ferryman here's
dragon know they can feel it sometimes
his emotions run hard you
taemi part Lisa sometimes he's so cold
it's like he forgets he's on camera or
laughs for no particular reason do you
think it's like a nervous tic oh yes
yeah really shouldn't be laughing at one
of them found out about it beat her up
so bad she ended up in a hospital in
Carrero Street dude what part of that is
funny smell that collecting the laughs
that was my task every laugh and every
hi and I didn't know what life was
anymore meant by the end of the process
I really felt like Tommy was still was
sitting next to me going do you
understand life do you yeah I'm a little
different now you guys might notice that
I wasn't an S Ju for about a week and a
half that's why I took the time off to
just go run in a park and throw a
football to myself cuz watching this
movie so many times in a row broke the
great thing about this movie is the
tummy we so obviously did like I have
the blu-ray and if you read the
description on the black back of the
blu-ray it's obvious even that he wrote
that because it's written in time Lisa's
like what do you ever really know about
life one day your girlfriend is with you
and the next day she's in bed with best
friend it's like obvious that he even
just like it's it's amazing right man
you gotta do it yourself the real
outdoors
yeah and I will I'm sure you know this
Joe even on the special features the
special features on the blu-ray
begin and end with the Tommy Wiseau
vanity card so it is Tommy Wiseau
productions in Globe special feature
Tommy we don't productively the trailer
the trailer for the movie on the blu-ray
starts with the Tommy Wiseau productions
card trailer ends with the Tommy we saw
everything is bookended by a Tommy
Wiseau productions
amazing he paid for it he did yeah all
right let's alright keep watching
continually simple love triangle where
Johnny is engaged to Lisa his wife of
the future you might future wife wife
screaming wife but she doesn't love him
I don't love Johnny anymore I don't love
him anymore
I don't love him but I don't love him so
she sleeps with more kiss movies a
little bit like Groundhog Day just keeps
repeating the same three scenes over and
over again with his but in between he
would set that aside because the room
has enough dangling plot threads to
weave up like this this man explained
game of tuxedo football Johnny's
promotion at whatever his job is
something red something appear and
disappear throughout the movie this drug
deal that's never mentioned again per
second are and the most casual I of
cancer of all time I got the results of
the test back I definitely have breast
cancer you are you gonna react to that
no cause for singing like I want to call
it the room of the room the room that
they're in right it's so like cramped it
looks like a like a rental furniture
storage shop with like deep red walls
it's just got some bad vibes but it's
obviously built on a you know I mean get
that and they shot this thing on this
the lot was the lot of the company that
rented them the equipment or sold them
the equipment which is like I'm sure
it's it's functional for like commercial
shoots and you know but like not for a
three-month long film shoot so it's like
all of the sets are obviously crammed
into corner yeah like yeah the room
itself is like it looks like a sitcom
set right which is even better because
of what's happening in it but yes
smaller and darker yes with more
furniture it reminds me of the other
screen turkey studio it's a
multi-purpose room yeah movies cut
straight that's my favorite John Reid
remember it is not almost cookies
where if a man makes at a badge on him
set up the equipment this is like a real
cinema verite like it shows it's so
surreal but it's also very real like if
someone in a movie does this watch you
see what everyone in for similar happens
this is my favorite so one of our
buddies in San Francisco this is an
editor I know editors I am one this I
promise you was included in the movie at
the direct insistence of flowers you'll
see exactly how that financial
transaction went down yes spoiler alert
it was weird just the best so much it's
so dense this is my son pruder film like
you could just do this frame by frame
right can we roll that back let's just
watch that again this experience and
this is only you know for time this is
only about half of that scene but I mean
just the amount of things that are
happening in this scene we can roll it
from here it was weird how much is it
it'll be $18
keep the change hi doggy you're my
favorite customer thanks a lot by aliens
approximation of human love ball and
play boy tries to join a threesome
three's a crowd - two randoms act like
toddlers while they do it it takes you
so long - Johnny does his neighbor just
close your eyes when your arm becomes on
trustus lot arm me so enjoy this
real-life version of springtime for
Hitler that's the pinnacle of so bad
it's good filmmaking spawning midnight
movie screenings Oscar caliber films
about its creation and remember veers
into our mystery Tommy Wiseau is where
he's from where his money comes from and
how old he is but some mysteries are
probably best someone freaks out and
anyone in a book group of your
documentary story football spoon art
sentences and exits oh hey guys I have
to go now I've got to go oh hi mark we
gotta go oh hi mark I have to go all
hidin again its hyper-realistic
fingers in real life people say hello
and goodbye oh I gotta go they just
don't worries don't worry don't worry
don't worry don't worry don't worry
don't worry about it generalizing about
women women change their credit move it
all the time you think girls like did
she like guys do I never say what they
mean and they always play games
sometimes are just too smart
somebody just flat-out stupid other
times are just evil oh this is the great
I think this is the great unsaid thing
about the room it's like hidden beneath
these layers of mystery and a wonder and
humor is like the fact that Tommy Wiseau
fairly plainly doesn't seem too fond of
women well it's a testament to how many
layers of of the yams are on this movie
that's not a but I would I would take
that side of the bet but the the other
side is that this is like a personal
revenge it's like revenge pouring on
somebody there was ELISA in his life
that he's getting back at by like I'll
show her I'm Mick movie where she's the
bad one I'm the Hollywood movie yeah
it's clearly like he's got a lot to say
I think he's making it broadly about
women but it seems like Lisa the Lisa in
his life he had ELISA hurt him one of my
favorite parts of the disaster artist is
there's a scene where the cast is all I
don't know how true it is the life but
there's a scene where the cast is all
around the table speculating about who
Lisa and I don't want to say but it's
like the I think the final conclusion
that they came up with like in the
others I was like oh my god they're
right yeah so yeah it may actually be
broader than what he's got he's got a
big problem with somebody yeah I promise
you
that lisa is was someone who had no idea
she was in any kind of relationship I
promise you she was a clerk at the
Chinatown Walgreens in in San Francisco
who he was just like weirdly obsessed
with she said I was her favorite
customer taking money from someone else
I make Hollywood movie wonder if you've
seen it anyways want to talk about it I
don't want to talk about it I don't want
to talk about I don't want to talk about
it I don't want to talk about it again
same scene yeah what smart in the room
the room very different come back to our
room playing a character she's just a
lady wandered in and started commenting
on what she saw what are these
characters doing here people come in and
out of this apartment every day this is
worse than Grand Central Station
good stuff said the room that's the room
the room it's nice yeah I was not
thrilled when I found out disaster
artist was coming out because that meant
the room was gonna get big again come on
people because you know I think we live
in a pretty insular like film nerd
community where everyone knows and has
appreciated and been sick of then
appreciate again the room but yeah let's
share with the world it should be shared
I got it
there was just a time where I realized
that owning the room was like a much
more low stakes gypsy curse of like
thinner where like if you owned a copy
it meant that if you had people over
someone was gonna go is that that thing
and then everyone was gonna talk about
it until you all just ended up watching
it's just it's tough cuz there's a
there's a hump initially but yes there's
literally the first 30 minutes have
three hump scenes it looks like it's a
port it looks like I was like oh the
first time I saw it oh it's it's a porn
yeah I didn't know that because it's
just him just thrust in a way at
whatever he can reach peen level is get
in the business and then and it stops
and then he does it again and then stops
then he does it again they're like oh no
I don't know if I can get through this
but for whatever reason it's really
front loaded with the sex I thought
maybe he thought literally oh yeah he
doesn't quite seem to get the mechanics
of it ya know do you think success has
made him happier or lonelier oh I don't
think he's oh I think he loves it
I think he's really taken to it he's
embraced it do you think like women like
sort of you know kind of kind of try to
pick up on him or whatever and he's like
oh this woman's into me but then they're
like no no in my belly button like you
do in the movie and he's like oh no I
think it makes him sad yeah we're not
gonna kink shame anyone on this show Jim
know the belly button they like your
other other other hole I think he
transcends things like emotion rational
thought yeah
it doesn't Enigma it does make me wonder
what kind of movie other San Francisco
famous crazy people would have made with
six million dollars because there's a
lot of them just work street performer
guy that dresses up like a bush and
scares the end of the the world famous
bush man just a lot of weirdos in SF
that could have made something
interesting with six mil I will say
other than I believe this is also set in
San Francisco or at least its Northern
California a movie that is almost to the
rooms level for me is Birdemic if you
have not Birdemic almost cockroaches
room level for me as far as like this
guy had a vision and he thought he was
making the best movie of all time yeah
okay and it's got just that innocence
about it like I think that bad move
really bad ones haven't haven't have it
earnest there aren't like that happening
like M night Shyamalan thought he was
making a great environmental Eco horror
movie yeah but it ended up being you
know the a discussion about hot dogs and
Mark Wahlberg talking to a tree and
Zooey Deschanel being a mannequin mm-hmm
but you can't you can't you couldn't
have made that movie if he tried
it's just they just have to kind of
happen they're like I don't know they're
like yeah comments this yeah you just
have to find them I think in terms of
those like what what sets the room just
a step above is the Tommy was so enigma
yeah that he because he is brilliant you
because I watched a ton of interviews
cuz I think my angle at first with this
was I was like I don't know what to say
cuz literally like the midnight
screenings are starring section yeah
what do we say so I was like maybe we
just talk about the world around the
room so it was like watching a lot of
interviews and he's brilliant in that he
never says anything people were like
well why'd you do this and he's like
well you know an understanding about the
world and people is how they look at
each other and sometimes there's a
football and we all wear shoes and so I
think whether it's because if he
answered questions honestly he'd go to
jail because this was all a
money-laundering thing and like it or or
the or if he's just brilliant and knows
that the less he says about himself the
more famous for saying that would
explain like the two sets of camera
equipment and everything he's just
trying to waste money to hide it well
he's saying it's you know like I know
that in the book they're always like you
guys like Tommy where'd you get your
money is like I so coats yes jackets
it's like if if you want more time he
was so stuffed there is a Tommy was so
character arc in his series of AV Club
interviews where they start very
friendly and the guy at doing them like
they get along and then but then the
deeper the guy tries to get with him
like those interviews and very poorly
where Tommy what's those like like screw
you and like like storms away and like
that said it's really weird but yeah
that's what he told them he's like I
sell jackets huh and they're like six
million dollars it's like yeah that
of thing next in the Eastern European
import-export business
yes exactly however that lends credence
because you know they also like correct
Aceros like I went to his apartment and
there were indeed racks full of jackets
so maybe that's true there's no every
time you think you find proof one way
you find something the other way yeah
that's I don't I don't ever want to know
I'm in the camp of like I don't want to
know I know that this supposedly these
people found out and what I don't know I
want all the answers to be putting a
time capsule and uncovered in yes yes
perfectly men I want that answer to be a
man found an old used mission and
possible mask and just put it on this
nice alright guys well that was fun and
bad and good and evil and all things
just like this episode of honest trailer
commentaries we'll be back next week me
Joe Dan for no but equally confusing in
dark movie yes and we'll see you then I
gotta go uh-huh
you
[Music]